Well, happy cone PP everybody.
Welcome to Densetsu vs.
Beasties.
Papa Queen!
I missed what I said.
I know it's right.
No, no, no!
Speaking of sides, why don't we start with introductions
from the Densetsu EXE side?
Hello everyone!
I'm Victoria Ruben!
Uh, yeah!
Inca, Inca and Retro Stuff is my jam.
And I'm part of Densetsu.exe.
Thank you!
Yay!
Uh-ohachi!
I'm Phoebe, your 2.5D blooming flower idol.
Love to write music and perform it on both the real life and
the virtual stage.
And I like Utschi's balls.
Utschi's balls.
Yeah.
I'm part of Densu.exe.
Thanks for having me.
Yuki!
Yay!
Oh.
Sorry.
You can do it.
Guys, she's new here.
She's nervous.
Can someone whisper the lines into my ear?
Oh, and boy, boo.
Yeah, yeah.
My, my, boo!
Six, seven.
Chris, early.
Yeah!
Now for the fourth member of Densatsu.
Yeah.
Steiner, I know you're in here.
Yes.
Oh, okay.
Well, nobody's cheering for Steiner.
Oh, that one.
So the next introduction.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Barry and I am a bug.
Hello, hello.
Hi.
I am formerly of Densetsu for, in parentheses, one day, one
day.
And then, but I'm a beasties member.
Yippee.
Oh, I don't know about that, but Torio, my name is Torio
Oriana, I'm also a ferryman, the most loyal member of
Beasties, might I add?
Oh my god.
Thank you, thank you.
Once we bring this home, I think that'll solidify us as a
unit again, isn't that right?
Is that right?
Hmm.
Home cheater.
Yeah.
No, no, no, no, no.
Guys, I am so, can I just say, Thiner DM'd me and he said I
should throw for, if I throw for the, for beasties and and I
let Densetsu win he'll make me gen 2
my name is Kaidu crocodile I'm a crocodile and I'm also part
of the beasties always been part of the beasties okay wait
hold on shall we the oh happy comb pp gremlin slime with the
heart of gold pp ufo slimyest member of the beasties at your
service but yes today is the battle of the brain smarts
versus the brain fart in Papa Quiz where we determine which
team has got the most brain cells of all of us
oh I wonder I don't know if I'm right but we just keep
captain oh I know this one I got it oh I got that so good I
got it.
I got it.
No, bro.
I keep tapping you.
I don't know.
I got it.
Wait, hold on.
I'm locked in there.
I'm blaming the ping.
I was so fast.
The ping.
Lippinasia.
A fruit?
I can't read this fast.
How are you guys reading this fast?
I brewed up AIM Labs before this collab.
AIM Labs.
We were ready, man.
We got so much time.
It's the ping.
It's the food.
I was training.
I know this one!
Wait, I hit put this up.
I hit butter!
You can give!
You hit butter!
Because it didn't.
Phoebe is throwing.
Flash, flash.
Flash!
Flash the crotch out.
Slash Clash has a crotch out.
Zoomer.
I got you with the cat.
Oh yeah.
Oh, Flash Flash.
Are you doing what she does?
This is best.
Yes.
Oh, yeah.
Top, top, top.
Oh, no.
Don't let her do that one.
Don't let her.
Let's go.
Dude, she's like an autoclicker or something.
She autoclicked England.
Please.
Autoclicker it over.
We're so close.
Oh, God.
Oh, I don't know.
Oh, I have no idea.
What is that?
I know.
it I'm guessing oh I think it's this one oh god it's the
wheel I already chose London Bridge I just hope I pray I
pray is that London?
No, it's Tower Bridge!
Yeah, it's Tower Bridge!
Can we talk about how Vicky and Pia grab was their point?
Guys, I'm the most British person here.
Oh my gosh, Pia!
Congrats!
I'm gonna do a really British dance.
Oh, that's so...
Wow, so British.
We all showed up in a yellow submarine.
A yellow submarine.
Whoa!
Pokemon!
Okay, um...
Coke him.
Oh, okay.
I figured out it.
Was I fast enough?
Woo!
Oh, so fast.
Was I fast enough?
Oh, steal.
Not me!
No!
Please.
What?
You're stealing from your own team!
You gotta do it for diving you.
Wait, wait, wait.
I have NPCs.
NPCs.
What?
Big Love, this is your chance again.
Not me, not me, not me, no me, no me.
What?
No, I only...
Bad Beasters.
The Beasties are all the very first four.
I'm Mr. Beard.
You're insane, you're insane!
You're insane.
The timing is weird.
I was looking at the screen.
I don't think we ever seem to like...
We always seem to all agree on this.
categories.
Yeah.
Oh, fuck.
I mis-collected.
Oh, my fucking linear keyboard.
I should have been fat fingers.
I should have been.
I'm taking the title from Yoviki.
I am fat.
Not that.
Hi.
It's time for the last round.
Why are they gone in style?
Yeah, they're gone in style.
The more points are converted to time.
Okay.
The more points you score, the more time you get.
Oh, no.
Oh, gosh.
Oh.
Last player remaining is the winner.
Oh shoot Teaching in Minecraft is often formed when lava
cools quickly.
I know I know Easy got this one.
Holy lady now you got it like under a frame Wait, oh guys
don't look.
Oh no.
I love Minecraft.
I need to play more Minecraft Famous catchphrases Hi dog Oh,
easy.
Oh, shoot.
I low-key...
Oh, okay.
Tori's really sweating.
No, no, no, like, I knew it.
I didn't know it until I saw the name.
You know what I mean?
I'll save us.
That's it, too.
You can do it.
Save us.
Oh, I'm hooked on geography.
Oh, no, wait, geography.
I don't know.
Um, I guess.
Uh, wait.
Oh, actually, this is going to be a zero goal.
Yes!
We've got a zero.
Seconds on her.
What the hell?
She's a hero!
Whoa!
Phoebe's second.
They don't want to be a part of Beasties Gen 2.
Australian.
I know this one.
I think I got it wrong.
I think I know it.
Dolly.
This one's a...
Oh!
No!
They feared the Beasties win that was about to come.
They feared him.
We're back.
We're so back.
Wait, wait, it won't let me in.
Wait, wait, what?
I'm putting up.
I'm, okay, okay, I'm in.
I'm in.
Disney, yeah.
For my group, you know?
I always believed in my group.
Who's Tommy?
Oh?
I know.
I don't know.
I know, it's gummy.
Woo!
Oh!
Gummy.
What?
Gummy, burs.
I got that right.
Gummy bears.
No!
Do I play by myself now?
Yeah, Mr. Burs.
Burs!
Mr. Beard.
Choose your victory dance.
Mr. Beard's victory dance.
Please, Mr. Beard, can I be in a video?
Please.
This is how Mr. Beard dances.
Bring it now, Mr. Beard.
Oh, yeah.
That's Michael Jackson.
Wow.
So you just gotta survive to the end to get your team a
point.
I think that's probably the fairest way, right?
Yeah.
I'm doing this for my team.
Grants, Beasties.
So was that a tri-round or did that round count?
Yeah.
You know, that's, we were learning how to play.
Yeah, that was a warm-up.
Yeah, warm-up.
That was a warm-up round from now on.
Yeah, and Vicky had to play in like a year so she didn't
remember how to play.
Yeah.
We didn't even know how to tap tap.
Even though we had a British, a British category.
I'm like fake British.
It's so crazy, Pia.
Yeah, it's so crazy in it.
It's so crazy in it.
I'm activating my third eye.
I'm gonna be able to answer all the questions now.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Can we have anyone with third eyes on here?
I got a secret third eye.
I have more eyes.
You don't want to know where mine is.
Oh.
Shee-day.
Is that allowed?
I ain't allowed.
Mine's up my butthole.
You can see the world with a totally different perspective
down there.
You two words!
I'm kind of scared, I'm kind of scared, I'll be honest, I'm
really scared.
Maybe we should have gotten to the funniest category, I
think.
Mr. Beast!
There has to be a Mr. Beast question.
2020 which of these youtubers has the most oh no oh it's
gotta be mr beast but he's not even on here wait a second oh
wait no still 2020 really he doesn't oh really 2020 2020 the
context is important Huh?
What is money is so kind of crazy.
He's kind of stopped.
Oh, hey, what's going on?
Really?
No way.
Viral philanthropy?
All right.
Just whatever.
Just whatever you say, buddy.
Oh, no.
No, it's not.
No, I don't want to mess about your thing.
I'm choosing nuts.
No, I chose the knife.
I'm not that guy.
You said it, cowards.
What's cooking here?
Yes.
Sorry, hello?
Oh, I answered it wrong.
Oh, I don't know.
Don't look at me.
What is the name of May's big neighbor?
Oh.
I clicked the wrong thing.
I went for a picture and thought it was a picture.
I swear I know it.
I swear.
Mr. Beard Lockett.
Yeah.
My little pony.
Oh, oh, oh.
What is not a my little pony?
Huh?
You hate me.
I don't know.
Oh, I messed up.
I went.
I was wrong.
Oh, they don't.
Oh, wait.
No, wait.
When was the first ballpoint pennies entered?
What?
Who knows?
Yeah.
And it's like super close.
I think Barry is.
I guess.
I just get lucky.
I'm lucky.
This is Indiana Jones' superpower.
He's just a guy.
He's just a dude.
He can turn into a snake!
Wait, none was an option!
What is Harrison Ford doing?
Wait, none of them.
He went the high way!
I didn't realize that none was an option!
Wait, what?
Two of them!
There were two of them, two of them!
She didn't!
What?
Lady Knight!
It's not here!
Not, not, not, not!
I ain't cheering that.
We got TV on your screen and enter the pool.
Wait, every set!
Wait, who is that?
Who's Lord Dude?
That's tiny, who is that?
Did someone join on their PC and their phone?
Wait, who is that?
Who is that?
We should just let them join.
I think this is just a random.
They could be the four dead sets, remember?
There is no chat.
Wait.
The code's not even public.
I think it's cool.
I don't know.
Oh, he's ready.
Oh, no.
I don't like Lord Finger being in our game.
They're all rooting for Lord Finger.
Lord Finger.
No, that's a Gen 2, guys.
That's a Gen 2.
Oh, my God.
The leak.
Lord finger
I know my pair trivia I feel like so does Lord finger he's
kind of doing bad I'll be honest
taste, dude.
Things that make you say ewe.
Ewe.
What is not found in snot?
What the hell?
So does.
Oh my god.
Big love.
Who would you like to steal points from?
How is it always big love?
This is crazy.
I'm stealing.
That's why I lock in for stealing.
Oh my finger!
No!
Oh my god.
Are we all gonna bully him?
Boy, they're on your team, so they're just giving you extra
food.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Oh, he's angry.
Oh, my God.
Oh, yeah.
The large finger or she marks.
Wanting to get down.
Wanting, you could learn some moves from that.
One, final fight.
All right, here we go.
Yeah, let's go.
They picked all the hardest, like, questions.
Don't fake them.
We're counting on you.
We believe in you.
Lord Finger are you British?
Oh my god I don't know Oh sorry wait a second I don't know I
don't know I don't know I don't know I don't know I don't
know I think it's Melbourne I tried no way Lord Finger
fucking clutch this up i'm fucking i'm fucking kicking lord
finger out yes yes hey i'm still here too i'm living here
i'm living here i'm living here buddy buddy enjoy your last
dance you are to the final supper this is your final dance
bud yeah good one good one banana bounce out yes who That
means it's one point Densetsu, one point Beastie.
So this decides everything.
Team Smart.
The decider.
Oh, my gosh.
Demon, like, beat us all and then...
Hey, I held my own.
I feel like I deserve one.
Yeah.
We need you.
We need you, too.
It's time for the last round.
All right.
Okay, this is where it all matters.
Here we go.
bring it back i'll bring it back i promise bring it back
bring it back last clear remaining is the winner i'd be
shocked if keo like won this to be honest that'd be like the
craziest combat you gotta believe in a mean way but who like
kind of who uses the comeback i know you are but what Oh,
children.
Someone uses that?
Someone actually does that?
I don't know.
I picked it!
Oh, shit.
I guessed it.
I love Pewee.
This is crack.
Why does that just like it?
That's the only Pewee Herman I know.
Oh, shoot.
I don't know geography.
I don't know.
I have no idea.
All right.
I don't know.
Please, please, please, please.
You know!
Rigged.
Where's history?
No!
What is celebrated the 4th of July?
Oh, you know this one!
You know this one!
I think.
I don't know.
Yeah!
Of course she knows that one.
It's your own therapy there.
That was crazy.
Rigged!
The team running the first MLB World Series.
I don't know!
I can't believe it's still going on.
RIG!
Oh my gosh!
Who's this?
I don't know.
Oh.
RIG!
This is so...
You have to pick something.
Drup!
Big love wins!
Who's that?
Big love!
You know what?
And also, I dedicate this win to my group.
congratulations so which is your now all right buddy your
victory come on my group you know the real ones no may i
just comment on the percentage of american questions in that
final round it started so british that i thought this game
was british because it was like right like the ireland and
whatever and then they slowly phased those out absolutely
ridiculous Congrats to both of us for winning.
We all won today.
Yeah.
We won it.
Very lost.
Yeah.
Team Densetsu.
Okay, guys.
This isn't funny anymore.
You won't be a loser.
But yeah, thanks you guys for coming to the collab.
Yeah.
It was so fun.
It was a lot of fun.
I love Beasties and Densetsu.
Aww.
I love Beasties and Densetsu too.
And also, in seriousness, I am a member of Beasties for
anyone who is uninitiated.
member of Beasties for now.
For now.
She mating after this.
Wait, she doesn't mean that she's leaving.
It means that she's getting kicked out.
Hey, you know what's better than MVP B?
MVP B Beasties!
Spring March available for a limited time!
Bye, bye, bye!
Unless you're watching this after May 31st.
Boo!
You missed it!
Maybe next time.